so it's Thursday and we do have new jobs
numbers another 1.3 million Americans
have filed first-time unemployment
claims meaning last week remember this
week we learned the numbers from last
week another 1.3 million Americans have
lost their jobs are you becoming numb to
these numbers to some degree I mean I
want to remind you before the 15-week
weeks in a row of coronavirus job losses
the previous single day record for new
unemployment claims was about 700,000
we've had as many as 6 point 6 million
in one week and continue to have right
under 1.5 million per week for several
weeks now and the reason that this week
is particularly important is that today
we got the numbers from last week in the
last week we have seen states have to
sort of reshot down elements of the
economy that's happening this week
meaning next week and the week after are
going to be crucial weeks in seeing
whether these numbers start to go up
again the rate at which Americans have
been losing their jobs has been coming
down we're still seeing people lose jobs
but we had six point six million one
week and then 5 million 4 million etc
the rate has been coming down things are
reclosing though and the next two weeks
could be particularly ugly last week was
more of a normal week you might say as
normal as things can be during a
pandemic and 1.3 million more people
lost their jobs so that's now 15
straight weeks of job losses that's a
total of 51 million jobless claims since
coronavirus started now I know people
email me as if I'm trying to deceive I'm
I'm mentioning we don't have 51 million
people out of work right now so 51
million people at some point lost their
jobs during the last 15 weeks many
millions of those have either gone back
to work or found new jobs so of the 51
million only about 18 million remain
actively unemployed right now and that's
obviously far better than 51 million
although still historically high so now
the question is what happens next week
coronavirus has forced California to
reclose sectors of its economy
indoor dining is done movie theaters a
whole bunch of stuff that had been open
is now closing I won't give you the full
list of states but there are many that
are having to go backwards in terms of
opening even Texas is is actually having
to step back so this week which will be
reported next week and also the
following week are going to be very very
important now the other thing that's
upcoming and I want to remind you about
it is that on July 30th we're going to
get the first estimate of second quarter
GDP second quarter GDP has been widely
expected by both the left and the right
to be maybe the worst economic corridor
for the United States possibly ever
possibly at we might get the worst GDP
number in 14 days that we have ever seen
in the United States the second quarter
of course was April May June at the end
of June some stuff was starting to
reopen a lot of the opening has happened
in July so at the end of this month
we're going to get an estimate of just
how bad was second quarter GDP I don't
know how bad it's going to be the
expectation is that it's going to be
quite bad and sometimes when you get a
bad number that's slightly better than
what was expected it actually feels like
hey we actually got off less seriously
than then we might have so I don't know
what the answer is going to be but in
terms of the timing July 30th we're
going to get an estimate of q2 GDP
August 30th is when we'll get a more
fine-tuned number and that is going to
be very very close to the election of
either Joe Biden or Donald Trump for
another four years and this is exactly
as we've been predicting for a couple of
months cases going up
q2 GDP number is going to be dropped on
top of us sometime in the next two to
six weeks with different specificity and
precision as we get more accurate
numbers by August 30th we are going to
have dramatically more information than
we have right now about what the end of
the year in early 2021 is likely to to
be for the United States we may also
have some vaccine news we
they also have news about therapeutics
so in my mind I'm sorry no I have a
question on Friday's show this week
about where do I believe the point of no
return is for Donald Trump in terms of
if he doesn't turn his polling around
and I'm going to make the case that it's
October first however I'm seeing
September first as a date at which point
we are likely to have a lot of
additional important information about
how things are going economic data case
data and much much more if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blink it's blink
Isleta consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst blink East
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video